next up Vice contributing editor Molly
crabapple talks about her collection of
political art and journalism this
program contains language some may find
offensive
to the powerhouse arena we're really
excited tonight to be celebrating the
launch of drawing blood by Molly
crabapple together round of applause for
that so this program is going to feature
a discussion followed by assigning right
to your left
so just so you know we've got lots of
copies of drawing blood up at the
register and we really appreciate if you
grab a few from us because it helps us
do really great events just like this
one for you guys so here's a little bit
more about our author and moderator
Molly crabapple is a contributing editor
for vice and is written for publications
including the New York Times The Paris
Review and The Guardian
her work is in the permanent collection
of the Museum of Modern Art and she
lives in New York City Matt for
moderator Matt Taibbi has reported on
politics media finance and sports and
has authored several books including The
Divide Griff topia and the great
derangement so please welcome our two
speakers thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Molly's first ever book tour
event so I want to bask in the fact that
this might be a little bit nervous
tonight it's going to be my hazing yeah
exactly yes if everyone wants to haze
Molly tonight this is your opportunity
I'm very honored to be able to be the
moderator for this event such a cool
book when I first read it I was really
blown away Molly and I obviously worked
together before I had no idea she ever
wanted to be a writer and then I was
doubly surprised to find out that she
was a terrific writer in addition in
this book when I first read it I thought
it was it reminded me a lot of books by
people like Charles Bukowski you had
these rollicking adventurous lives and
in addition were great artists and
that's that to me is the way this book
reads like a diary or a darkness is that
is that what you're part of your
motivation was with this oh dude you're
making me blush this isn't a good hazing
visit thank you so much well the first
question I guess is why I switched to
Ricketts you come to this later in the
book but the decision to become a writer
and to do a book I mean if I was as good
as you are at drawing I would literally
never do anything else how did this
whole transformation come come about I
hadn't always wanted to be a writer
actually and I wrote this really really
terrible not novel when I was in high
school that time-travel it's really bad
it's kept at the bottom of my drawer and
will hopefully be burned upon my death
but give us a synopsis of the book so
you know when you take the quirks of
really good writers like Nabokov but you
don't take anything else good about them
just sort of their superficial quirks
and you do that was like 20 writers and
then you all try to like hammer them
together into one manuscript right
that's kind of like that what about the
plot exactly it's about a girl who gets
magic physics textbooks that lets her
travel to all of the historical errors
that I was personally interested in and
she gets to hang out with everyone that
I thought was cool Wow
yeah I know yeah how old are you when
you wrote this 16
so learning how to use a bong at eating
so see you had friends and I did not and
that this is this is why our lives went
these ways actually no it was funny when
reading your book found like that we had
a lot in common a lot of negative things
in common when I talk about some of the
earlier passages in the book one of the
things he wrote about was that you grew
up angry
what were you angry about I mean I grew
up angry too but I didn't have any
reason at all to be angry I came from a
perfectly privileged household my
parents were strange but apart from that
what made you angry
because you're a child how could any
child any thinking child not be angry
you have to ask some of the permission
to use the bathroom right yeah of course
and you talk about that later that um
that creativity thrives on constraint
you think the constraints of childhood
you think that's part of what art is is
breaking out of all those constraints I
think yes because you have to have
something to push against right you have
to something that makes you jagged so
often you see these people who have
become really really eminent and to many
writers conferences and junket sort of
smooth off all of their interesting
jagged sharp edges they just become
these sort of round dull things that's
what happens we have no constraint I'm
familiar with us and I'm not actually
will talk about your childhood your
mother was an artist one of the things I
remember when we first met I was really
struck by that I was really impressed by
was the way you talked about your
mother's attitude towards art your
attitude towards art that it was just
something you did for money and you got
used to it after a while that it was
just like a purely commercial activity
you talk about that well you loved it of
course but you also view it as a trade
the same way that you know carpenter
review something is a trade you view it
as something that you're good at
pointing said job so often people don't
go into art because their family's view
it as this sort of like Airy thing
you'll never make a living at whereas my
mom and not just my mom but my mother's
family were people who were working
artists right and when she had a cheek
get her started I could you had her it
was your great-grandfather was also an
artist who sounds like he was a lot like
you you was a compulsive drawer right
troublemaker you talk about him a little
bit I'm a great number bedroom right and
I never met I've never met my
great-grandfather my great-grandfather
Samuel Rothbart was a member of the
boond which is a revolutionary socialist
Jewish organization which is probably
why he left Russia during the failed
revolution in 1905 he was an artist a
compulsive painter a perhaps slightly
too rebellious for his own good person
and he had a basically he would haul out
his paintings onto the lawn every
morning and called it the rossport home
museums direct art and he thought it was
competing with MoMA and was going to
take it down yet you still have those
paintings we do yeah my Matt my mama and
I'm so husband a member what do they
like are they like your work they're
kind of like post-impressionist stuff my
favorite of his though and I think the
one that has the most familiarity is
that when he was an old man he did these
paintings he called memory paintings
which were about life in the shadow and
some of them were kind of you know
weddings people baking bread UHN of
usual things but some of them were like
Jewish girls sucking the Russian guys
behind the shed Wow excellent because it
was it was a true jockey a true
documentation of it that's why I see the
similarity they were they were almost
journalistic even though they were done
from I don't know like 70 years removed
and it was him the compulsive drawing
was that just something psychologically
that he always bitter that started after
he came to America and when did you
start doing that oh man me I have been
drawing since I was 4 it's just how I
deal with the world if I was locked
alone in a dark room I would draw I
can't not draw and there are these two
impulses that artists have right we have
the impulse to draw pretty pictures of
people we like so that we can gain your
affection yeah so we can have friends
because we need bribes for that and then
we also have the impulse to draw mean
pictures the people we don't like right
right
yeah you have a you have a line in there
later that there were there's basically
two different kinds of paintings right
there's the
there's the one that that you have to do
to make friends right but then there's
the secret horrible paintings of what
you actually see exactly this is the
secret horrible treacherous things like
look at look at Goya right Boyle with a
court painter but one of his most famous
things is this painting that shows the
royal family in all of their horrible no
chin inbred just trauma and disgusting
this right right and you feel like
that's that's what you're doing with
your career is you're you sort of given
up doing the pretty pictures to flatter
people the stuff that you do now is the
real gritty horrible version of life
that you actually see or how does it
work I mean I think you do both like I a
lot of people I draw I are people that I
admire I mean whenever I do my stories I
always do them from a place of
admiration even if they're the worst
story in the world even if it's the most
horrible thing I did a piece recently
about these long-term solitary
confinement prisoners called the dallas
six who they were blowing the whistle on
human rights abuses got hideously beaten
up by the prison charged with rioting
which you can't do in solitary
confinement obviously but what attracted
me to it wasn't just the horror and the
evil of it was that these guys were so
smart it was that I admired them right
so sometimes you're doing it's not
always the negative horrible thing right
not always a negative horrible thing and
not always flattering saying either but
sometimes I don't know I think if I had
a through-line it's really [ __ ] smart
rebellious people who maybe you're
getting kicked around by the world but
they want to kick it back a bit right
you wrote in the book that you drew
pictures of people so that they wouldn't
hit you was it really that bad oh my god
dude you have no idea I I was such a
[ __ ] brat man I I would have hit
myself sometimes I look back I read my
old journals for this and I was like oh
now I understand what do you understand
exactly well you know you always frame
yourself as a hero of your own story in
your head and obviously going to wrote a
book starring myself do I know this but
the particular story in the particular
stakes you think are played out when
you're 14 are not accurate
right well what-what exactly did happen
I mean you you you wrote at one point
and your mother's here in the audience
so and my dad is here in the audience
oh really hi how are you doing you wrote
this amazing line that you know I would
have doubts my childhood and lit a match
what what was that was it really that
bad what was so it's not that my
childhood is that I've lovely parents
it's that when you're a kid you're
chattel right I mean you you're nothing
you can't decide anything you're you
have no choices you have no
self-determination I mean why were you
so angry because I was an idiot mostly
mostly and I came from a bad family life
but apart from that so you you found
this outlet in in drawing talk about
when you've discovered SLUSA Lautrec
because it does seem like that's very
much a style that you adopted you did a
lot of posters written in a very similar
way how old were you when you when you I
guess it was like 11 or 12 I want to say
my mom always introduced me to my dad
always introduced me to art a lot but I
was immediately obsessed with him
because he was the house poster artist
of the Moulin Rouge because his family
were inbred aristocrats he was born a
little person and then he caught
syphilis very early so he suffered from
horrible medical conditions because it
wasn't treated at the time and he took
all of his bitterness in his rage and he
channeled it into this work and he did
work that's both of profound empathy for
people who never get empathy like like I
think he of every man who has ever tried
to draw a brothel I would say that
Lautrec was the only one who got it
right in what way because he drew the
women as fellow humans they weren't
symbols they weren't symbols of ruin
they were in symbols of beauty they
weren't symbols of desire they were just
like women being like oh what a day
right but it wasn't it was different
from other kind of poster art from the
age right can you talk about the way
that he was different whether well other
poster artists from that age they were
all about
let's show a good fun beautiful
wholesome time whereas toulouse-lautrec
was like no no it wasn't about that
let's show an evil time let's show a
time when there is like [ __ ] class
war that's being played out in
nightclubs
and did you when you were that age did
you did you already know that you wanted
to be ours at that age oh god yeah I
know I I knew who I wanted to be an
artist for forever it was just from the
AG like four or five yeah it was either
be an artist or be a writer but wanted
one or the other and so you go to school
you have this kind of Goffe existence in
high school and but you're desperate to
get out right get into the real world
and what are what are your first
real-world experiences center school
well you go to you go to Paris which is
like the one part of your book that I
thought was a little bit it's like every
memoir of the artists we have to man
it's like like a role we don't we don't
get you know we're not allowed to work
otherwise right yeah exactly
um so I worked at Shakespeare and
company in Paris which was sure which
was this amazing experience because
Shakespeare Company was a place where
you could work for an hour a day in
exchange for living there and not even
work well I was very unconfident let's
be honest I no one should ever have
hired me for retail to being confident
in cash register we didn't have a cash
register we had to do the addition
ourselves and we were just kind of make
up prices on the spot Wow Wow and also
concoct lies about why they ought to put
money into the Wishing Well so that we
could like later scoop it out and buy
liquor with it did you vary the prices
depending on the people that you saw
there people you didn't like to charge
them more etcetera etcetera I feel like
they should they yeah I would say yes
so the Shakespeare Company in the book
it becomes kind of like your home base
every time you get in trouble you return
to Shakespeare and company you buy a
ticket back to Paris and you go back
there how many times did you go back and
forth the Shakespearean company man
like four and then for that period in my
life and I go back there whenever I'm in
Paris now but it's not the same I mean
for me not not the store isn't the same
though it isn't but for me it's also not
the same because I'm not I'm not this
like crazy grubby little drifter kid
like I was right
so you first started going there in your
late teens early 20s and at 17 when I
first went in your first one okay and
then there's this amazing part of the
book where you decide to become just
enjoying the sex worker business and the
the first part of this is the sex worker
business that's I don't I don't know how
to talk about it but there's the first
section of it is so unbelievably
disgusting about these these guys you
call G WC s guys with cameras and they
sound literally like the worst people on
earth can you talk a little fun night
they were just they were they were just
dudes I mean basically these they were
these guys that probably would have
liked have hired a private stripper but
they didn't want to think that they were
the type of guys that would hire a
private stripper so my job was both to
like be naked in the hotel room with
them but also concoct a delusion for
them that they were a sophisticated
artist who was making legitimate
artistic product by taking lots of
photos of me and I'm someone really nice
and sweet some of them were pretty
hilarious one guy had me posed with
hundreds of hard-boiled eggs in a
warehouse and he like was really
offended by the idea that anyone would
think he had an egg satis she's brought
this up and he was like I don't have a
fetish well then why did he have all the
eggs they're beautiful in his word so
you would have to stuff these guys out
in the first few minutes and figure out
what it was that would allow them to
feel comfortable with their own
delusions right can you tell stories
about some of the weirder or more
difficult situations there was that one
guy who paid a lot but was really rude
and disgusting so there was this one guy
what he really got off on was insulting
women and so you know I posed for him
and he gave me a lots of money but he
just really critiqued my body in pretty
harsh terms and I had a friend of mine
and I was like
you know he'll you'll get $400 for two
hours but he'll probably be really mean
to you because that's just the sort of
person he is
and the whole time that I was posing for
this guy he was like your tits are awful
man but uh this other model her tits
were great so when my friend posed for
him he said to her he's like your tips
are awful but Molly's tits were perfect
why can't you a good trip like Molly by
the way he looked like The Hobbit
and in the beginning when you first
talked about this it seems like you're
really uncomfortable with the idea but
pretty quickly you get over it and you
talk about how you're a sleek machine
for extracting money yes did you
actually did you take a lot of pleasure
in this surge it was just the the fact
that you were making more money or what
was it well it wasn't that like I
thought it was like so fun to pose I
mean posing is uncomfortable but it
wasn't and it wasn't just the money
though I certainly did like it but it
was the idea that I could get the money
in a way that wasn't approved of that I
didn't have to kowtow to the traditional
like trajectories of things I didn't
have a degree I wasn't working retail I
was breaking the rules and defining a
life on my own terms that was what was
so good about it and you find that
liberating right yeah I found that
liberating and I hate I hate discourses
about the sex industry that are like is
it empowering is it not because I mean
who cares you know that that doesn't
matter but is getting paid what you
would in a retail job in 3 hours
empowering yes that's absolutely
empowering and there are all these
amazing stories of things that you went
through during this period you talk
about the crickets oh [ __ ] oh God
so I was hired to pose for a music video
shoot and I was hired to kind of be the
girl in the bikini it was a really low
budget heavy-metal music video thing and
I was really broke and they said okay we
want a poor live crickets on you and I
laughs crickets are gross right those
little feathery legs you know and I
negotiated that they weren't wouldn't be
on my face but it's like fine you know
right either you specifically yeah
no fat no face and some like lying there
and my like $15 bikini on the asphalt
and then the grip poured them on my face
and burst out in laughter because
because so much of it it's there's like
a lot of anger that there's like a girl
that's hot that's not sleeping with them
that they have to pay to be around them
so why not pour crickets on her face do
you think a lot of this was an
intentionally demeaning just because the
crate the cricket thing was yeah yeah
definitely but I demanded to get paid
extra I and I wouldn't sign a model
release until I did there was a really
cool line during this section I wanted
you to expand upon a little bit what you
wrote that cool is not meeting and you
weren't cool yet what do you mean by
that when you think of someone who's
cool what makes them cool is what they
don't want right that they're not like
begging someone give me love give me
money give me affection give me
attention the essence of the cool is
just that they're they're standing there
like an indifferent object and then
other people are petitioning them
whereas at that stage in my life all I
[ __ ] wanted to do was make it as an
artist and that's I was epically uncool
so the fact you hadn't made it yet MIDI
made you uncool the fact that I hadn't
made it yet that I wanted to oh it was
the one thing that made you uncool and
did you ever get over that huh I don't
know see if there's something really
obnoxious about artists right where we
think we're Outsiders long after we're
inside like there are so many artists
there's some of the artists or writers
that are like [ __ ] millionaires that
will be standing on the stage speaking
to an audience of like 20,000 people
being like oh you know I'm just like a
poor poor girl you know I'm still I'm
still outside so I don't know whether I
ever got it it got over it or not I'm
not
I only know what's inside my own head
but at a certain point you have to stop
pretending you're an outsider right um
so can you talk a little bit about the
evolution of what you're drawing during
this there's this time period obviously
you start and I've seen you with your
notebooks you you have a process and
this maybe just goes back to this thing
that your great-grandfather said make
art every day you're constantly drawing
stuff whether you whether somebody asks
you to or not right and that started
very early in life
right remember when we heard misdemeanor
court together oh yeah I'm like drawing
mcmean pictures and stuff yeah that was
amazing what Molly and I did is she
helped me with my book and we went to
this misdemeanor Court where people were
basically being sentenced for peeing on
the street and yeah it was the waiting
room of institutional racism they're
exactly like her for obstructing
pedestrian traffic and there's like this
whole room of people almost entirely
non-white who are just there to get
their tickets for for something cops of
allegedly seems in doing and Molly is
like smiling and going around each
person in the in the place and drawing
their pictures and everything yeah and
then this court officer I drew this
picture of him serves like a pustule and
he got so angry everybody else had these
really flattering caricatures but the
but the judge in the the bailiffs didn't
do so well right you know sometimes
people's inner soul influences what you
draw right but in terms of my just style
I mean I I always dry draw compulsively
I have to do it but then it just got
more and more detailed it got bigger and
bigger at one point I did like an art
show of giant paintings one of them you
know based on one of your articles yeah
I want to get to that decision of when
to start making those epic paintings but
you started off doing pen and ink
yeah pen and ink and in little notebooks
and was that throughout your entire
childhood up until wet and you still do
it right I still do them yeah I mean I
still do I have like a stack of
sketchbooks it's probably bigger than me
at home um I guess I did it because a
pilot pen is kind of discreet you can
get it anywhere but it looks kind of
like in a door it's like kind of
old-fashioned looking the result but it
only costs $1 right right and that that
kind of did you ever work with ball pen
till you mentioned that a few times in
there Oh God he was mocking me for this
backstage so when I was 12 I was really
into zine and I was so proud because I
did this picture of this like really
scrawny girl with like really long hair
in front of like a big spiderweb stained
glass thing and said Requiem at the top
and I was like this is so cool and I
sent it off to a Z and
they it was ended in ballpoint pen and
it sent it off to the zine and they sent
me a letter back that was like this
artwork is lovely but we don't accept
artwork with misspellings in it cuz I
boiled right why does that matter
but in generally I used I used pilot pen
and then like slowly I learned how to
use color or slowly I you learned how to
use more advanced things slowly I let my
style get looser I let it I let it get
more splotchy I started looking at
steadman [ __ ] Idol I I started let it
letting the ink express itself in ways
that before I was I guess scared to do
you know how it is it's like when you
learn your medium so well it a certain
point you get bored of absolute control
over it and you just you want to let it
do the worst thing that can possibly do
and then make something good out of that
right right and so you started branching
out later you didn't start doing the
these gigantic epic canvasses until
later but before we get to that you the
whole idea of so you were working with
these GW C's for a while then you had
this episode with the Suicide Girls can
you talk about that just briefly as a
Suicide Girl back in the day one of the
first ones right no they were there were
a lot I mean I I wasn't I was not like a
founding them all but Suicide Girls was
really interesting because it had this
thing that when there was a big scandal
around it was ascribed to the sex
industry that wasn't about the sex
industry at all it was actually about
cool companies there's a model with sort
of cool companies whether they're
American Apparel or a record label or
whatever where because they're like cool
and indie seeming they get everyone to
do lots of free work and put in a lot of
unpaid labor and then they get lots of
like venture capital and get lots of
money but they're still like relying on
the free labor and they like we're cool
guys they over time we're not going to
pay you and Suicide Girls was very much
falling along along that model it's
interesting because you talk about your
mother's three rules because that kind
of violates the rule of never working
for free right
my mom says free free rules where what
she told me I should be a teacher which
I would be very ill suited to she told
me I should not move to the suburbs
because commuting kills your soul and
she told me don't Allah straight people
unpublished children's books for free
nothing ever comes so as more still is
more specific than you said in the book
basically in the book Italy don't don't
do anything for free basically right I
think I think I think she probably
advised that too but particularly
children's books everyone thinks they
can write a children's book and they
always come to you with them and they're
like take my take my horrible five
sentences and make them beautiful right
right for free for free yeah it was
funny because I had a I had a mentor in
journalism who gave me very similar
advice at an early stage in my career
and he had three rules also and the
three rules were don't write anything
for free never write about Israel and
when you when you're really shit-faced
drink a liter of water before you go to
sleep so those are the four three rules
of journalism so so this whole time
you're drawing in pads and you're trying
you're trying to get ahead in the art
world as well you talk about some of the
breaks you had to cover for screw
magazine which I thought was really cool
like I would I was really I was really
proud of it I mean my actual cover like
my actual artistic skills at that time
are not so but I mean everyone cool work
for screw magazine like Spain Rodriguez
worked for screw magazine dame darcy Joe
Coleman
everyone all the underground artists did
cuz you know it once you're in the space
where you're drawing porn you could draw
anything like the porn wasn't even the
point it was just that you could do
anything you can make it a sticker as
weird as you wanted we could open like
the first sort of superficial tattoo
right right and and when did you sort of
make this transition into becoming sort
of a journalist I mean was that around
the time of occupy which is around a ton
of occupy cuz I I guess journalism rubs
off on you like a rash or something
because I turned my apartment kind of
into a press room and all these other
journalists were around me and I I guess
I was really tired of the idea of
artists being these sort of like mute
observers stuck in their studio never
actually saying anything and my first
big published piece was actually was
right after I got arrested and I was
really mad and it wasn't just because
like my arrest was particularly bad I
mean I had a stupid arrest but it was
fine but
what happens in Occupy protests and it's
like very very tall pink top came and
arrested me I think because I was short
and looked hapless and he thought it
would be easy and I was in jail for like
11 hours it was it wasn't it wasn't a
big deal but even like 11 hours in jail
was so shitty and awful that it made me
so angry that America have used this as
a totally acceptable thing to do to
black guys for standing on the street
like like it's not even worth commenting
on like so much of white America thinks
that just being arrested is fine
probably because I've never experienced
it right right and what was it about
occupy in particular that drew you to
the to the movement I mean it you didn't
really you had these arguments about
politics with your father you talked
about in the beginning but apart from
that you don't really talk about
politics until you get to that that
section of the book well I mean I had
you know been a lot of anti Iraq war
marches and I had done sort of there was
a a lot of activism around sex work with
this amazing magazine called spread you
know back in 2007 but I had never really
been seriously involved in in political
things and that was because first off I
I thought it was really boring I hate
meetings I [ __ ] hate them like I'm
just going to be honest like I am
probably will never probably a bad
leftist just because I if that's the
future I don't wanted to do it um and
then also I I guess I didn't feel that I
was I didn't feel that I was
intellectual enough I I felt like I'm
you know a naked girl that draws tits
and stuff I I don't I'm not good enough
to be here that sounds [ __ ] up with
that that's true there was there was
that in my head and but occupy with such
an inclusive space that I didn't feel
that way there I felt like it was for
everyone right and so you just sort of
started showing up and you were doing
all kinds of things you were you were
driving posters you did one that worked
it worked its way to my desk which is
really cool but talk about some of the
work you did during this period when the
first work around occupy was I'd noticed
they didn't have any graphics it was
like three days in so I drew a vampire
squid based on Matt's article it's how I
know him by the way because he bootleg
t-shirts of my yeah which I later found
out was a big no-no okay I was fine I
thought what that when people were
allowed to do
um but I did this sort of right the
vampire squid stencil then I started
going down I drew pictures of people I
did lots of posters I did a poster for
the general strike in May 2012 to play
on the word strike it had like a Latina
woman she's like striking a match
excellent excellent and then you did
shield game then I did shell game and
when I first saw shell game the first
thing that came to my mind tell me if
your get insulted by this comparison was
it was very much like Hogarth it was
like this yes I can look my comparison
are you kidding me I love that yeah
because it's this gigantic epic
progression of things and you know these
huge paintings with lots of minor
details that are like allegorical and
all that so much work had to go in each
one of those things you talk about the
process once my [ __ ] life every
single one I would so there were nine of
them yeah yeah there were nine of them
they were all based on either
antagonists or rebellions of 2011 so one
might be about like Syntagma square
protests in Greece one was about a
Goldman Sachs one what might be about
like health insurance one might be about
riots in London but I would research
each of them like a journalist would
like I didn't review all the
participants and I had asked them stuff
not just about big things but about
visual memories like I remember
interviewed uh Paul Mason who's
journalist did a lot of work about
Greece and he he said the thing that
struck him most was seeing people where
their eyes were covered in white because
they would pour anti acid into their
eyes to counteract your gas and so it
was just like these like white strips on
their eyes and so I drew that and I
would take all of these experiences and
his memories and gossip and I wouldn't
make them into a visual metaphors and I
would have like a big allegorical woman
and like little allegorical animals and
I didn't I did nine of these but they're
so so so detailed I mean the one about
occupied even has a [ __ ] drum circle
and like the other Oracle mice like
hiding their ears from it and the
process was incredibly can you talk
about just the physical process of how
you did that because I when I was
reading it I was stunned by it I mean
there were multiple people involved in
different stages of it and
talk about that so the first thing I
would do is I do lots of sketches I'd
make all these notes then I would do a
super super detailed pen and ink thing
that was like yay big
and I projected onto a board and I had
an artist assistant who would trace it
out to trace up my drawing onto the
board and the board would be like six
feet tall like sanded and gesso it I
mean so much this manual labor goes into
art like this is people people want to
pretend that art is just like some
[ __ ] thing in your head but it's like
blue-collar labor also you know you know
that's actually fun of these day because
again one of the first things that
happened when Molly and I met is that I
was asking her about the possibility of
doing a certain kind of drawing and he
said [ __ ] my hand just hurts thinking
about that you want to make like it was
an animation or something or like a Joe
Sacco type know what the Joe Sacco type
books I look at him in like so many
lines so many lines right exactly
exactly and that's that's one of the
really cool things about this book
actually is that it gives you a sense of
of what the actual physical work of
doing this stuff is like and how it's
not always all that much fun and and
it's you know it's a really laborious
process it's something that they blank
out of it they always want to pretend
like it's just like you're God like I
think it and than it is and no it's
actually usually you making like really
really repetitive hand gestures over a
board for like an entire month and then
it looks beautiful at the end but the
entire time there's nothing sublime
about it at all your hand just heard and
you're on the phone your dad or your mom
exactly like they reminds me of editors
that I've had you always want me to make
changes and they they act like it's fun
for me and I'm the changes that's how
they feel artistic that's their creative
part right and I'm like you must be one
of these people who thinks the
prostitutes enjoy the sex you know it's
like it doesn't it doesn't work that way
actually this is this is work so you so
you do though you start you made these
amazing 9 paintings for occupy shell
game net and you had a show after that
right and then in the road you start
working provides and you become this
kind of like multimedia
multi-dimensional
journalist / artist can you talk about
the significance of that in terms of
what you might think the future of this
bit because I think you and I have
similar feelings about this that the
idea of somebody who is who does lots of
different things all at once is probably
going to be necessary and in the way in
terms of the way the medium is going to
develop in the future so many times when
I'm asked to talk about like the future
of journalism I think that problem is
the the problem is the singular because
there is an infinite number of features
of journalism's I mean if there's one
thing that is the future of journalism
its multiplicity it's much nests
it's the fact that the audience is dead
the source is dead the reporter is dead
it's the fact that everyone is screaming
all at once everyone has megaphones and
the future is that cacophony and perhaps
what I have to like offer to the future
of journalism it sounds so [ __ ]
pretentious is just that sense of doing
everything because that's what the
future is just everything it's all at
once
it's your part of the story in some
cases right you're you're writing about
the story you're drawing a story there's
video there's all these things and and
you're also writing about things and
participating in them at the same time
yeah
and that in advice gives you a lot of
license to do all these things alright
yeah they've been they've been amazing
to me I mean I my first real
investigative piece was revised by
Guantanamo I just got my security
clearance to go to Guantanamo and then I
went to Vice told them I got that and
they gave me everything I needed they've
always had my back
they unlike a lot of other places don't
demand that I change things to be pro US
already they don't demand that I give
like a pro already side which I really
approve of I got to write an article for
size by confronting Donald Trump on
Sunday right from the proudest moment
look what did Trump say to you he
doesn't do anything he's like mouth
puckers like a little pink anus and he
didn't say anything and it was like this
really was silence and Ivanka's too but
then I got yelled at by the the
publicist too and then other people said
I'll always remember this it was the
best follow-up question was mr. Trump
you stand for luxury Dubai stands for
luxury is that why you love Dubai that's
a fastball right yeah good journalism
good journalism there so you have this
tremendous advantage as a journalist
that I don't have and that most people
don't have which is that yeah you can
meet people in a foreign country that
you with whom you can't even communicate
in their language but you can draw them
and incidentally create a report it is
that you had all this bizarre foreign
travel really early in your life and you
got to have these relations that we're
pretty close with people in all these
disparate places can you talk about how
being an artist helps with that
well cameras are kind of alienating in a
lot of ways I mean you're taking like a
big chunk of metal and you're putting it
in between your faith and theirs and you
know who knows what you'll do with the
photo will the photo be used against
them it can't see the photo everyone has
lots of photos taken if them because I
have their own cameras there's no like
great thing about having your photo
taken whereas most people haven't been
drawn or they've only been drawn once or
twice they can evaluate you while you're
drawing them and tell you if you're full
of [ __ ] exactly what you're doing and so
it's like you're putting yourself on the
line when you draw - I mean they can say
if you stuck to your face right there
and I kind of have to collaborate with
you a little bit cuz I have to stay
still usually so so many times I mean I
just I just hang out and draw people and
as we all know the best things that
happen in interviews aren't when you're
asking lots of questions it's when
everyone's relaxed and you're just sort
of hanging out and chilling right right
and that process for most people takes a
really long time to get to that point a
minutes yeah yeah you don't develop into
some intimacy in five seconds with
people but with with a when you're in
you're able to draw somebody they can
immediately see what you're all about
right and that it has to be an
incredible tool for you to use I love it
I feel so lucky that I get to do that I
mean I remember once I was in Abu Dhabi
and me and the amazing guy who is
translating for me and the amazing
journalist who was helping me roll up to
this labor camp and like we're like
stuck in aliens like why why are a bunch
of or wire like two [ __ ] white people
like showing up to a [ __ ] labor camp
or where all the workers live it's like
why and I just like it was the guys day
off so they had set up this kind of
makeshift barber shop outside to earn
some extra money and and I just started
sketching it and at first they were what
are you doing and then they left and
they're like oh man that's my friend you
got his big nose you draw my other
friends here and I just got to like hang
out and chill with them because they
thought it was cool you know who does
that who just draws people right right
and you know you don't have to ask and
pestering questions the entire time you
don't have to you know be on schedule
with them you can just hang out and draw
on yeah and a lot of times they would
just tell me things and then I was talk
to them while I would draw right to
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed get to see your
pictures
I think college Sheikh Mohammed knew
what I was doing but he didn't get to
see my picture that I know of so maybe
his lawyer sent him I sent him a thing
of it you talk about that experience
going to Guantanamo Bay Guantanamo is
that is single akwonton mo is that
obviously Guantanamo is a [ __ ] evil
place but it's evil in the most American
possible way it's like cheerful
self-congratulatory and victimized and
like self victimizing evil like Quentin
let's go to the gift shop it's a place
where there are a big gift shop yeah
Guantanamo is a gift shop what's what's
in the gift shop
you sure to say it don't get no better
than this no teachers for little girls
it's a Guantanamo Bay little princess
because it wants to pretend it wants to
pretend that it's just a normal
Carribean military base with nothing
sinister going on whatsoever and so of
course they would have a gift shop in a
karaoke bar and a McDonald's of course
you know there's a karaoke bar too this
is America what could they possibly do
it be doing that's wrong yeah I remember
in in Iraq there was a Cinnabon and a
base that I stated and I I thought that
was really necessary for the war effort
but but a karaoke bar that's that's
amazing
and so you've you've done can you talk
about some of the other stories you've
done for Vice you've traveled all over
the world and you're you've been - back
and forth of Turkey a lot I've been to
Turkey a lot I went to I went inside
Syria for like one day I was recently an
Iraqi Kurdistan with dr. Scott waters I
have done stuff and
Lebanon um perhaps if I'd done stuff I
just did a big like American prison
story I I mean I feel so lucky that I
have a place that will both give me the
freedom to spend months investigating
prison stuff do you know how long prison
stuff takes it takes forever right I
mean even just to get your letters to
the prisoners takes oh they mean the
arranging of getting into them yeah the
Irate or even the getting contact with
the prisoners themselves and getting a
set of phone calls and getting set up
meetings everything you know takes
forever right right
they'll give me that sort of like
luxurious time that I feel like so rare
to get but they'll also um you know
publish like quite quite spontaneous
things than me too and yeah I mean I
I've gotten to travel a lot so and I
think one of my pieces that I'm really
proud of was I was able to UM go to Gaza
this year and I did a piece about a she
J which is neighborhood those completely
destroyed it and look at me just like
violating your rule here no no J bag
about writing it right and writing about
Israel it's alright you can write about
Israel but but my mentor told me not to
write it but Israel because he said that
no matter what you say you're going to
piss off 50% of the people so uh even
more even more it's something somehow um
but I was able to you know be in Judea
and interview these people who's like
home to the completely flat and but they
were living in them anyway and and draw
it and I mean it was I felt like it was
such a [ __ ] privilege to be able to
do that and not have someone like
censoring me or like trying to force
this like weird fault even-handedness on
me it was and just let me write the
facts as I knew them and what I saw so
what's what's the future now for you I
mean do you envision yourself writing
books forever dude or are you going to
go back to doing this colossal art or
everything involves suffering doesn't it
it's like it's like either I'm going to
be like locked in my studio doing these
giant things are going to be like a
horrible unbathed troll demon writing my
book it I mean I don't know I was like
come on actually for a book where you
literally don't wear clothes while
you're doing it right yeah no I don't I
I were like my boyfriend's like paint
stained and
like spills encrusted shirts nothing and
nothing else um but I mean I don't know
I guess like more of the same but bigger
and better but presumably a break in
there somewhere I'm not good at thinking
about the future I've never been one for
like the Stalinist five-year plan and I
think our world is also too much influx
to lend itself to that but do you see
yourselves as journalists and artists
all of the above all of the above
all of you both just a couple of lines
that I wanted to ask you about because I
thought they were so interesting
these were aesthetics mean more than
morality what is it what does that mean
to you well in the context of a drawing
I mean we all know those like horrible
[ __ ] preachy lie you know propaganda
paintings but in the context of the
drawing like well you're drawing because
I was talking about when I was wrong
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed with that line
and while I'm drawing him I'm not
thinking like this is a guy who murdered
2,000 my neighbors I'm thinking how do I
make his face fit on the page and the
bright in the right way right and then
they're also a conflict with you know
especially when in journalism you want
to tell the truth about everything but
when you do you're going to lose your
sources at the time people were trying
to get information from if you did you
draw it to accurately you're going to
lose that person aren't you well I mean
Guantanamo wasn't very pleased with me
I'm asking article they the PR officer
actually called up vice screaming that I
had made him look like a tool and I
almost didn't get my security clearance
to go back and I didn't find this out
until I was in Florida and I learned
about that but it gave it to me at the
last minute
and I don't know if I'm welcome back
there or not you get that a lot of
people I knew an artist in Russia who
who said that one of the things that he
people would say up to him all the time
was ethany Yahoo which in Russian means
like that's not me in other words you
draw people and they object horribly to
your characterization of them is that
something happens often I remember one
time I was it was in Gitmo actually I
was drawing a Rear Admiral Rear Admiral
Butler who was the man in charge of Jim
O'Neill at Rear Admiral Butler who
decorated his office with as Ruhlman
yeah his really deter Admiral Butler
Rear Admiral Butler a decorated his
office with
beautifully slick photos of detainees
being like sort of marched off places
that Tuesday core and he had a big book
that you flipped through with all their
names in it night I didn't really like
Rear Admiral Butler much and I wrote I
was I think he thought that I was just
like some little woman or something so
he was like very you know gallant and
charming to me and giving me this
interview and then he saw what I drew
and he just sort of was like oh that's
nice and this is a business that mean
forget about drawing and forget about
art even the written word is kind of
going out of style I mean almost
everybody gets their information from
video these days has it been hard to
find a niche for yourself as somebody
who you know is primarily an artist herb
was first an artist you know what's
strange there are two ways to have a
career one is just to be the best right
but that was never me I've never been
the best at anything but the other way
is to be so [ __ ] weird that you have
no competitors and that anyone kind of
who comes to you they want you and
there's no competition you can name your
price because no one else does what you
do because you're so [ __ ] weird and
you instead of trying to be the best of
many you just become entirely yourself
the only one I'm the only one is there
anybody who's even remotely a Molly
crabapple out there there's that an
amazing artist named Suzy Kegel who does
Illustrated journalism like I do but her
beat is technology in Oakland uh-huh
so we have a wide distance in between
what we do have like a little
nazi-soviet non-aggression pact yeah
yeah yeah exactly as she's uh she's
Eurasia okay so you get everything else
she gets technology in Oakland that
doesn't seem like a very fair spot she
gets the whole technology I don't write
about that so um so when did you decide
to write this book and what I mean that
you're very young to be writing a memoir
oh come on you how old are you in row
you're at the Exile book well that's a
true yeah it goes 27 27 foot yeah yeah
so you're like five years younger than
me right right right
but what prompted the idea to do that I
hada I started out writing personal
essays I only actually think had five
published pieces ever but when I got the
book deal and people really liked them I
I had this delusional fantasy that since
I had written a two thousand word essay
that writing a hundred thousand word
book would just be like writing fifty
two thousand word essays that wouldn't
be that hard ha ha ha and there's a
really interesting process in the
beginning that we were talking about
before the event that I want to ask you
about you were talking about how most of
the girls who were Belle stories in
America go a certain way and you wanted
to do a different way can you talk about
that a little bit well it's like for
white girls or the line is that white
girls are supposed to turn their anger
inwards they're supposed to cut or
starve themselves or sleep with guys
that are mean to them and that's the
accepted narrative and the accepted
narrative is then like you know they get
they get redeemed and they get returned
to healthy heterosexual metrosexual sin
but not unhealthy obedience and
informative yeah and I just was like how
about they turn their anger outwards
okay so this this book is not Girl
Interrupted in other words all right no
it's not Girl Interrupted no okay all
right Lex it's a great book I love it so
much I think everybody else will too
should we open up the for questions to
the audience yeah let's let's open up
big sort of questions look at other
blank faces while we stare at them
that's right I forgot to ask about the
box the question is about the box which
is a club where you worked right yeah I
worked at the house artists for the box
from the time I was 24 on for a few
years and the box was like the temple of
New York boom years it was a place that
the guys who wrecked the economy would
spend 20,000 dollars a night for cheap
champagne with sparklers in it Wow but
also my friends like my amazing
performer friends be on stage and they
would be doing these acts of like such
beauty and anger and like rigor so it
was the most amazing place but also you
kind of hated everyone in the audience
so much and I got to chronicle that yeah
do you think that kind of played into
your whole occupy vibe later because you
had already had this experience being
sitting around with these people and
then oh god yeah I mean well as my total
SLUSA Trek fantasy including all the
like the anger at the audience that he
had - but I mean you saw the guys that
wrecked the economy attempting to dance
- it's Britney [ __ ] and what were they
like as people up close so they weren't
brightest bulbs in the drawer right yeah
no no they weren't and very very
entitled like you could never say excuse
me at that club because no one would
move all right any other questions Wow
all right
the only place I ever really felt afraid
when I was in was the day that I went
into Syria cuz there have been a lot of
kidnappings there and yeah it was
dangerous though there's a section in
the book where one of your numerous
boyfriend's in the book which one which
one was that
what was angry about the fact that
you're travelling alone everywhere and
and yeah and he was he thought that um
it was a unique quality to me that I was
getting straight for Aston Morocco right
but it was just just my fault no it
never happened to anyone else's it was
always your fault right yeah though it
was always my fault and well the cuz
there's presumption that women aren't
supposed to travel or really do anything
fun I mean every single fun thing that
women do is something that if they're
ever raped
they'll be blamed for doing this fun
thing you know like don't drink don't
travel don't hitchhike don't go outside
at night never ever leave the house lock
yourself inside an iron box and if you
don't you know you probably deserve it
so yeah I mean that sort of fear of
doing anything is really beaten into
your head and there's never a moment in
the book where you were you're like
wondering whether I should do this or do
that no no no it only comes up and one
other people mentioned it to you yeah
well I mean what what's the alternative
like not live a complete an equal life
right right
we did a book together yeah yeah we
already did a book my my last book that
divided Molly Molly did the cover and a
series of drawings on the inside which
and it's all amazing Molly also did a
number of really cool posters for occupy
that were based on some of my articles
and some gel game at one of the actually
couple that were sort of page one of
them was based on yours but the great
American bubble machine one right but
the squid appears a few times and what
does this question yeah but yeah no
definitely I think especially in terms
of the Wall Street stuff I we saw I died
I died definitely on a lot of these
things when I think it really came out
well
so when I was 22 I started something
called dr. sketchies which was really a
reaction to problems that I saw with
traditional art classes I was an
artist's model and it was really really
objectifying and not unlike the sex the
objectifying way but in the like I'm a
chair objectifying way like I'm going to
demonstrate how an elbow works because
I'm not a human just an elbow
demonstrator and I had all these friends
with these amazing performers and I
wanted to do like something where
artists would draw them but it would be
a sort of a celebration of them as muses
I started this in a dive bar when I was
22 with no money it went to like over
100 cities they did it in Shanghai and
stuff I haven't really been involved
with it for five years because I made my
own art career got so big but there it's
still happening in New York and I
believe you went to it in Singapore and
it's so [ __ ] awesome I mean I it
gives me such joy that this crazy like
art fantasy I had when I was 22 is still
going on over ten years later now I did
however learn from it that I never want
to be in a managerial role again that it
doesn't suit my personality anybody else
I'd rather quote I've never actually had
a block period because I draw for a
living and drawing for a living is
inimical to blocked periods between the
block period you die in the gutter and
the quite the question is about whether
or not you have had block periods but it
would be impossible in your cases you're
literally constantly drawing right yeah
yeah I mean I just I even when I don't
feel creative I like just draw my hands
or something you know there's not really
I mean I just I draw like sometimes I
draw like deep sinky things that I have
to like really see your eyes but a lot
of times I just I draw eyes I try hands
I mean I don't know I just draw
everything it's it would be like having
a part of my life where I didn't breathe
or talk question is whether New York is
an artist friendly place or not not if
you're poor it's not I mean I mean it
hasn't it hasn't really but the thing is
though artists were the parasites of the
rich right where they're lampreys and
New York has concentrated the rich onto
this little tiny island so I still think
it is a place where you can live and
where you can make art and you had Ken
like scheme out a living for yourself
cut it is [ __ ] hard it is hard and
harder every harder every year and
you've told me some pretty funny stories
about some of the patrons that you've
had you've completely misunderstood what
your work is about but they're willing
to pay right oh my god so there's this
guy that wanted to buy the original of
the book cover I did for Matt actually I
didn't sell it to him I he was a dom
entrepreneur and he told to me i really
want to buy this
I love Americana he shoulda sold it to
him they're my they're my children I
don't want to send them to bad homes I
actually have that piece yeah you have
anything I'm very proud owner of that
painting yeah yeah it's beautiful
oh and thank you for the art in the book
is wrong if you've been to a lot of
different places right is there a space
where well maybe a you wouldn't dare to
go with your journalism or art or be in
their place that you haven't been to
that you wouldn't like to go the
question is whether or not there's a
whether there's a place that you
wouldn't go and it or is there a place
that you haven't been that you would
like to go
I wouldn't go inside a back inside Syria
at this point because I'd be too scared
and I think it's too dangerous and where
I would like to go god I'd really like
to go to everyone around someday or
Pakistan I mean so fingers crossed now
you do have a problem incident you wrote
about this in the book a little bit that
in some Muslim countries that there's an
issue with drawing animals and trying
other things I've never had a problem
with it myself except once one time this
like jerk when I was in Morocco this
like Salafi jerk took my sketchbook and
ripped out the page and tore it up in
front of me and I was really really sad
and then like the next day I went back
to that area and like this young guy had
had actually like taken the torn up this
is the drawing observe taped them
together and he was like yeah that guy's
a total dick don't don't worry about him
here you go but that was the only time
I've never had a problem otherwise was
it one more yes
the question is whether you do consider
doing another project like we can hell
and know cuz I've already done it
alright thank you so much for coming
appreciate it thank you guys and thank
you Matt this awesome
[Music]